[Music]  Beyonce pulls out of Coachella et can  confirm that Beyonce will instead  headline the annual festival in 2018  Beyonce announced she's pregnant with  twins just weeks ago which made many  fans wonder if she'd even be able to  perform at the festival in April now we  know the answer to that question  according to a statement posted to  Coachella's official Facebook page the  35 year old is quote following the  advice of her doctors to keep a less  rigorous schedule in the coming months  Radiohead and Kendrick Lamar are still  scheduled to headline their nights at  the - weekend festival a replacement act  for Beyonce has not yet been named  [Music]  you